si on veut faire que cet endroit soit
juste on doit parler d'une seule voix
comme un seul groupe qui me suit
booth est devenue folle nous on est en
colère on est tout en colère vous avez
été déloyale avec notre copine monsieur
caputo
et nous exigeons la justice à qui de
droit
nous les détenus de litchfield sommes
des êtres humains
nous contestons les conditions abusives
dans lesquelles nous sommes retenus on
va leur en mettre plein de vue super
n'oublie pas de sourires des yeux
est ce que tu sais ce qui se joue ici on
est battus sans raison nous en tasse à
quatre dans des couchettes comme des
poules en batterie on nous refuse des
droits humains de passe je peux donner
demain des filles elles vont pas t'aimer
c'est l'histoire de ma vie tu fais ce
que tu as à faire tu ne dois rien à
personne si on avait une chance de
montrer comment auxerre c'est parce que
vous vouliez
si tu es face à un problème alors qu'une
cher c'est ici ma maison et je vais me
battre pour elle on peut avoir des
revendications aucune idée n'est une
mauvaise idée aubrac un de placer des
cours de latin une pièce sans gravité ou
un flou très et on pourrait faire plein
de culbutes hockey certaines idées sont
de mauvaise idée dit à cette femme ce
que nous voulons nous voulons que ces
fils de [ __ ] nous prenne au sérieux
r'way
[Musique]
la seule issue possible pour nous c'est
de soutenir l'entité
[Applaudissements]
il y a plus de force dans un seul et
unique messac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de puissants esprits
nous sommes prêtes à vous recevoir
[Musique]